CBS News confirms the Department of
Homeland Security will bring
unprecedented DNA testing at the border
with Mexico as soon as next week now the
Department says the program will target
human traffickers who are smuggling and
exploiting children it also hopes to
slow illegal crossings that have
overwhelmed border agents Matea via al
is along the border in Hill delgo Texas
Matea good morning
well good morning DHS officials tell us
they are launching this program because
since October they have found about a
thousand fake families trying to cross
the border illegally simply put that's
where an adult is paired with a child
who they are trying to pass off as their
own
now this proposed rapid DNA test will
involve a cheek swab then in about two
hours results will show whether an adult
and a child are actually related now a
private contractor will conduct the
pilot program at at least two locations
right now a record number of families
mostly from Central America have been
crossing the southern border this year
and I recently spoke with some agents
who say this is a very frustrating and
sad part of their job most of the
families that come through here with
children are genuinely looking for a
better life but they have actually seen
cases where children are being used as
pawns because smugglers are telling them
right now it is easier to cross as a
family I've actually talked with one of
these agents who say that they
referenced a case where a young boy was
smuggled several times apprehended
several times over the last few months
come in with different men that were
actually not his family the ACLU is also
weighed in on this they say right now
the DNA testing will intimidate and
deter asylum seekers and while the DHS
has the samples and all the data will be
destroyed after tests are run the ACLU
warns the fact that it is even building
out this surveillance and infrastructure
should trouble us all now a little side
note about this technology it is very
similar to what law enforcement uses out
in California after wildfires to try and
connect families with potential victims
Gail losing some interesting questions
there thank you very much Maria